welcome to this video play Clark Kent
Clark Kent from the US this is Superman
right I'm not really an expert on on
comics known but this is Superman
dangerous um okay I do the reverse grown
prieta interesting line could be Katie
three interesting I can play t5m hmm
there should be six I guess not sure
what this is it's interesting we have
some sort of Dragon formation now
reverse tell us but he's played this a
three rupee one not quite sure if this
is helping him much suddenly playable I
mean I'm not saying it is bad but the
tough to sort of from get two groups
with this position okay I'll play a five
just trying to prevent be formed and
maybe you can play it anyway technically
sometimes you can do that takes takes
Knight takes this 95 takes takes Bishop
takes is also 95 hmm maybe okay he's got
the idea maybe to take on b6 but ok so
94 or is this luis no I think I can do
it Bishop takes pawn takes Knight be 5c
six is good for black I mean good for
black yes sir I mean I'm just winning a
piece but I'm trying to say
nitey em okay okay okay I'll take ya
that's a third typical position for this
reversed Sicilian black has got some
space which is nice or you lost me to
play a form and the y term has a very
healthy structure and sometimes can use
them we can squares on the queenside I
don't mind to play that with with black
but why does not in bad shape or
anything I wonder if b 5 is a mover la
b5 and rook c8 it's maybe a bit risky
but Bishop c6 specialty five for a pin
and I'm intending to play c5 of course
just grabbing space and space combined
with the bishops is so very nice to have
maybe you can play before here before
takes on b3 and pass on my techs with
the idea nights if five maybe okay but I
can take knight takes Bishop d5 you know
black black should be okay in a way it
shouldn't be terribly bad this also
always a counter play against e2 he
allows me to take it and give the check
check which I like to do a course
therefore there is 94 so this is not
really good I wonder if this is an idea
however somewhat looking at the a3 porn
not sure really what to do maybe I
should have played by 56 I was a bit
scared that there was 97 or something
but I can take a 3 all the time age 6
was was just lots of it lots of the move
really stupid ok well that's good news
this opens up the position enormously
and I can get maybe even two to d4 with
the bishop okay rook takes Bishop g4
this isn't this a winning material quite
surprising yeah it should win at least
exchange white Rosario yeah yeah step by
step I think white I got pushed
backwards here I don't know this this
might be already quite good for me it's
just um black asses the potential to use
the four against three here supported by
the bishops and white does not have much
much active play
ah the computer is suggesting this one
interesting yeah I'm just stupid yeah I
was intending bishop d5 but of course he
can take it with the check and win this
is working but I didn't see it hey I
didn't see this line and it's
interesting in fact this is what the
computer is giving calling this equal
but I didn't see any of that very lucky
yeah I mean no everything's fine i think
i mean just very nicely coordinated and
this was stupid on this move not this
this one does not really help anything i
can just play this one immediately with
a good game yeah but he gave it
completely away here with this
blundering this this exchange or peace
this was somewhat better but still it's
not good it's an open position of a very
good Queen on d5 very good bishop and
the night does not have a stable post
and he's got problems defending d3 and a
3-cell black is an excellent shape okay
yeah well thanks for watching